there is another type of ramen coated
skimming the noodle it's a little
thicker and it's usually serve the code
and you will dip in a hot broth
unlike ramen the noodle it's not sitting
on the soup you will take it off a play
and dip it in the blocks the noodle
itself is separated with the soup you
dip the noodle into the soup like soba
noodle but it's a little different in
pan of the broth this style is not as
popular as ramen but I feel like it's
getting very popular sometime if you go
to a restaurant the broth is different
and they get created a lot of ramen
restaurant will have skimming on their
menu so if you like ramen you should
give a try or try making this recipe at
home it's very easy to make broth is
very condensed and very thick I think
it's a great summer noodle recipe here
not sloppy hot broth out of all like
ramen instead of you will have a nice
refreshing cold noodle energy this
recipe is also developed by Daiichi in
50 Japan most of the ramen recipe are
developed by him because he loves noodle
so much this is a different type of
remember if you love noodles and a
urogram and i'm sure you will love this
also there is a trick to make pasta into
ramen flavor noodle so when you're
avoiding water add 1 tbsp of baking soda
and add angel hair pasta and once you
cook the noodle it tastes like ramen at
all it's a great hat I want to make a
video about it but I haven't had time
yet so yeah I was just telling you it
now
if you don't have an Asian market or
access to ramen noodles just boil a pot
of water and other baking soda and it
talks and it does the trick
[Music]
the last time I had a skimmer
it was Haneda Airport in Tokyo and when
I went to moderate they had a hammam on
the airport through the court I feel
like some Airport step up their airport
few games the same community it's very
refreshing and it's very different from
ramen if you never try it please try
this recipe I'm sure you will love it
[Music]